استطيع ان اؤكد لك بانه خلال الساعات
العشرين الماضيه وحتى الان لم يتم العثور
على اي احياء تحت الانظار فيه جميع مناطق
سوريا المنكوبه حتى ان الاصوات التي كانت
تحرك فرق البحث اصوات البشر تحت الانقاذ
التي كانت تحرك فرق الالفاظ يتوجه الى
مبنى الماء هذه الاصوات ايضا خفتت وانقطعت
بمعنى انه لم يعد هناك لربما فرص كبيره
للعثور على اي احياء جدول تحتها هذه
الانقاض رقم الوصول الى احياء او انقاذ
احياء كان
463 يبدو ان اضافه رقم واحد فقط الى هذا
الرقم الجيد سيكون صعبا للغايه وفق ما
نسمعه من فرق الانقاذ والفرق الميدانيه من
المتطوعين شباب على الارض العمليات
تنتهي في مدينه حلب بقي مبنى واحد في مركز
مدينه حلب لانتهاء اعمال البحث هو الانقاص
في هذه المدينه تم الوصول الى 53 مبنى من
اصل 54 مبنى منهار بينما يعني الجهود في
هذه الاوقات تتركز بشكل كبير على بلده
جنديرس مع وصول فريق من المتطوعين
الاسباني نطاق البحث
اتسع بشكل جيد في هذه المدينه
جنديرس ولكن في حلب تحديدا بما انه ذكرت
بانه على ما يبدو جهود الانقاذ تشرف على
او تشارف على الانتهاء هل لديك ارقام
لحصيله الضحايا في حلب تحديدا حتى هذه
اللحظه
يعني حلب حتى هذه اللحظه مقسمه بين
منطقتين احدى واحده للنظام وواحده
للمعارضه يعني المدينه مركزها بيد النظام
وفق احصائيات وزاره الصحه هناك 352 شخص
فقدوا حياتهم وفق وزاره وزاره الصحه
التابعه للنظام بينما في ارياف حلب يعني
العدد كبير للغايه في بلده جنديرس لوحدها
هناك 103 اشخاص فقدوا حياتهم حتى هذه
اللحظه فيما لا يزال يعني المئات تحت
انقاض يعني 84 مبنى مهدم بالكامل في هذه
المدينه يعني نحن نتحدث بان حلب بشقيها
تتبوا يعني ارقام من فقدوا ارواحهم على
مستوى سوريا
وتاكيد يعني بلده جنديرس ستكون الاكبر من
حيث عدد قتل هذا الزلزال في سوريا